i get the first headline they say so
here we go starting with the latest
vaccine news
cbs news reports that pfizer has
completed a study and found their
vaccine is safe and 100
effective for kids this is big ages 12
to 15.
so pfizer plans to file with the fda for
emergency use of the vaccine for kids as
young as 12.
you know i know drew that there's still
some va vaccine hesitancy but that's
changing
you know i've heard people say why
didn't i never got the flu shot the
difference is
if you didn't get the flu shot it only
affected you if you don't get this
vaccine it affects all of us and the
people around you so
i think this is very exciting especially
for kids because they can go back to
school
i don't know about frankie and olive but
aren't they sick of just looking at a
little zoom zoom
everyone has hit a fatigue level that is
so real
and we know we're here for a little
longer so the sooner we get vaccinated
the better it'll be out of it back to
life have you i've had mine
i've had mine too so can we say we
approve of the vaccine for children
i do approve okay yes i approve
i agree can i just tell you a funny
thing chris rock said to me
because people are saying well i don't
know what's in it i don't know if it's
safe and he said
you don't know what's in thailand all
either but when you have a headache you
take it
because you know it'll make your
headache go away yeah you know if it's
something that makes you feel good makes
you feel better
and until we have information to the
contrary
i i don't know i'm a big proponent of
the vaccine
i i am too and uh in all of this
um difficult roads that we are all
navigating
i have come to have a new re
appreciation for entertainment yeah me
too
i think when the world falls apart you
just think ugh entertainment uh
you know bigger bigger picture problems
and then you're at home for a long time
and you just need an assistant
entertainment please exactly so a show
like bridger
tin the steamy netflix hit that broke
records is coming back for season two
it's been a personal favorite of mine
glamour reports that the show plans to
take some real-life inspiration from
former royals harry and megan
and in season two the characters simon
and daphne newlyweds
new parents will go through some
struggles similar to megan and harry
i think being royals having public
opinion
being new parents are sort of the
similar through lines
gail i can't think of anyone we've
looked to for the north star
other than you and oprah for all of the
truths
from harry and megan i think that
interview
opened up conversations that many people
weren't prepared to have or didn't want
to have
but i think ultimately it's it's about a
family that wants to be united and be
together and i'm hoping that that
that will be the case and have those
difficult conversations yes
yes sometimes conversations are very
difficult
yeah right now i'm just happy for them i
saw in the paper the other day that
you know they said that they're planning
for a home birth i think that that's
interesting
i i really admire hearing all the
details
and opening up that important
conversation and
really making history in a conversation
that was refusing to be had
for centuries so i'm very happy that
the lid is off and it there's nothing
healthy about not
having those tough conversations there's
nothing healthy when you don't talk
so let's all wish that for all involved
in that particular story
okay gail your story up okay my turn
again
this is a good one a writer cosmopolitan
recently admitted that she misses
eavesdropping on awkward first dates i
love this you know we all miss going out
to restaurants yeah you do with your
friends you also miss i'll bet
sitting your strangers and listening to
their private conversations
can you relate to this hello my name is
gail yes because haven't you been in a
restaurant and you hear a conversation
between a couple in particular
and it's not going so well or you've
been on a train or you're even walking
down the street
and you get a snippet of something i've
actually turned around
turned around and walked behind the
person just so i could hear the end of
the story
are you one of those people well you
love nancy drew so yeah
i do perfect sleuthing i do i really
miss it it was funny
tony um decopo on the show literally was
like yeah you know you guys should
try not dating apps and meeting in
person i'm like have you read the room
the last year nobody's in person
yeah of course but i do think that his
point
is is important because i think we will
get back to that
um and i tried a dating app for a second
you did i did inspired by bridgerton i
was like i gotta put myself back out but
did you go as drew
yeah did you go as your drew face you
have to be honest
no way to start anything on deception i
know but drew i would do it
i just don't want people to know that
it's me i think also right now i'm a
little confused like is it my
girlfriends i miss
because for me the truth is and i did go
on a date with a guy and he was like you
know
and i was like no no no don't listen
kids work girlfriends alone time
fifth is the guy like but wait you
started to say he said you know i
what was we we were both talking about
like why relationships are complicated
and um and i was like i i think i'm
really clear about it it's sort of my
fifth priority
and i understand that's going to be a
problem yeah i guess it is yeah
all right well today we are tackling the
spring cleaning on the show
and in that spirit we must debunk the
latest viral underwear mask
videos on tick tock are claiming that
you must replace your underwear every
six to nine months
and i'm here to tell you they don't
think this is small
absolutely false also like how many
pairs of underwear are we talking about
well i mean i just think number one
i have you know there i have bras that
sometimes you're putting a safety pin i
know that's bad
i know that's right but i don't
understand why you'd get rid of it six
to nine months because it's still in
pretty good condition
i think if you have multiple pairs
you're probably okay
well i have multiple pairs don't you i
do we're in the same pair
of panties and that in that case i would
suggest
hygienically disposing of them but yeah
women in home
ask doctors and experts and they say
there is no expiration date
so good it's not like a toothbrush i
believe that they're underpants
and look at the variety that you're
showing see those are pretty i feel like
i should rock
something more like that i feel like
that's why we're single
we don't want to wear granny panties no
no you wear granny
no i don't really granny panties no
i'm not wearing little thongs either but
no i'm not wearing granny pants a
sensible sexy
panty yeah does sensible and sexy go
together drew
probably not probably not i started the
show in a g string i'm proud to say i
was really feeling myself
now i'm down to granny's i gotta get
back on the horse